What do I say? I don't know what I say. What do I do? All right, so I'm going to finish my peanut butter. It's probably really annoying to hear me chew a peanut butter sandwich. What might be a little better is... This is my apple juice. Guys, if this episode of Smartless is as delicious as my lunches right now, you guys are fucking set. Welcome to Smartless. I have a 1.30 pick up and a two o'clock crew call and 2.30 shoot time. So Jason's describing his first day of work, which is tomorrow at a fish market at two
in the morning. He has to shoot in a real fish market that's smelly and stinky. Yeah, the hours of operation is two to six a.m. So that's when we have to be there. And there was a time in my life when I enjoyed those hours of the day, but I don't anymore.
So my first day is gonna be, I'm gonna try to be warm. I'm gonna try to be welcoming. It's gonna be rough. That's two in the morning's rough. Yeah, I don't know. I guess I'm gonna go to sleep at six or something, try to sleep for a little bit.
Or should I just stay up? Should I just go get a big fat bag of white and stay up all night, Will? Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Let's pump the brakes on that. Should I just start counting days again? No,, let's pump the brakes on that. Should we just start counting days again? No, let's just pump the brakes on that. Okay.
So I said to Jay, he was thinking of opening first day gifts or whatever, you know, start gifts. And last night I was with Will Jason and I said to Amanda, I said, the cookie thing, there's like a new place in New York that makes pie cookies. Can you believe Sean knows about that? And they also make croissants stuffed with cookie dough. It's amazing.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. Croissants stuffed with cookie dough. That's right. Yeah. And what do you think I said to that pitch as start gifts? Do you think it was a no or do you think it was a yes? Well, I'm just trying to imagine your tone.
I bet it wasn't considered friendly. No, it was very judgy. Yeah, shut me down immediately. Sean and I were talking on the weekend. We saw each other last night, JV. Yeah, that's what Sean just said. Yeah, and we were with your wife and I spent a lot of time with your wife last night.
We started talking about, I've been freaked out this weekend, and Sean, I mentioned this to you, we started talking about, because you read, I sent you the article, JB, I sent you the article about kids with smartphones. Yes. Yes. And it's been freaking me out. And that guy, Jonathan Haid, wrote that book, Anxious Generation. Yes, this is crazy. And it's been freaking me out.
And that guy, Jonathan Haid, wrote that book, Anxious Generation. Yes, this is crazy. And it's kind of, I spent the weekend like talking to my kids about it. And you know, what this smartphone has done to this young generation and like the super increased rates of depression, anxiety, even sadly suicide of course.
And it's like, it's really sadly suicide of course. And it's like, it's really bummed me out. And I've just been like. Well, what'd the boys say about it? Well, you know what's funny? Did you talk to them about it? I did, I talked to them a little bit about it. And I said, you know, what you gotta remember is that these, some of these companies are trying to,
there are people out there who knew that this stuff would be addictive to you guys and they fed it to you. Like big tobacco. In a way, in a similar way. And I was like, how does that make you feel? Do you feel angry? And they were like, yeah, I feel kind of pissed off
because I feel duped. Look, we're all guilty of it. We were talking last night, like how many times you're talking to somebody and you've got your phone and you go, hang on, sorry, what? Like your attention is divided. And so I do it as an adult and imagine what that does. If you're a teen, it's even harder.
And this is a moment where you're establishing your neural pathways. And I said to Sean, I go, the richest richest man my 13 year old has the same phone is the richest man in the world. That's crazy. Yeah they're all the same phones. I don't let I'm nervous about my kids like going out or walking around the corner or whatever and yet I'll let them get on their phone and go to the far deep reaches of the internet. I don't know I got gotta change. Anyway, that's been kind of dominating my thinking. Something to do, something to figure out.
Something to figure out. Well, how are they, are they able to manage boredom? Like, do they have coping skills for like riding in an elevator and not doing anything except staring at the wall or sitting at a red light and watching traffic go by? You know, like that's something we had no choice but to get comfortable with. And it has, I'm glad I have that skill. I would be very anxious without the skill
of managing boredom. And that boredom led to creative thinking. Thought, yeah, exactly. Do you wanna hear my thoughts when I'm sitting at a red light? Can I guess? Yeah, you can guess. Is there a fart joke in here somewhere. It's good. It's the thoughts are glazed or cake
Sprinkled or no sprinkle hot fudge hot fudge caramel fuck it both So I don't want a phone taking all that away from me hot caramel fuck it both hot fudge caramel fuck it All right anyway look it I'm not we're I'm not, we're not gonna, this is. We're not gonna solve it today, but yeah. But it's food for thought. This is someone who's as delicious as Glazed her cake. She is extraordinary. Oh wow. She is a hoot and a half, a real firecracker.
She has a starburst tattoo on her right foot. What? Yes. As an actress, her body of work is ridiculously vast, and yet she's still younger than any of us. Known in Hollywood for her transformative character work and strength on screen, you might be surprised to learn that her fear of flying goes as far as needing to meet
every pilot before takeoff. Will's gonna bond with that. When not in the cockpit, you could probably find her working on a Ryan Murphy project, or 12 of them. It's still lovely and delightful, and her good friend Sarah Paulson. Sarah, get your ass out here. Sarah Paulson.
I covered the camera with toilet paper. Toilet paper. Sure you did. It would've been better if it was clean, but. Use toilet paper. It's not clean, so. Are you in the bathroom? Sarah.
I'm upstairs. I'm upstairs. Yeah, near a bathroom. You live in New York. This is your apartment in New York? I don't live in New York. I'm just here while I'm doing, yeah, near a bathroom. You live in New York. This is your apartment in New York? I don't live in New York, I'm just here while I'm doing the play. But this is your apartment,
we're visiting you in your apartment while you're doing the play. I'm actually staying at a friend's apartment, renting that apartment. Gotcha. And the play, we should mention. Is that the Tabasco Theater, by the way? It's at the Spicy Tabasco Theater.
That's really the Belasco. That's where Sean won his Tony. And Sarah's well on her way to hers. Tony, yes. For, yes. It's the golden touch of that theater, Sarah, I'm telling you. In her incredible play called Appropriate.
Everybody, if you're. No, no, Appropriate. Oh really if you're- No, Appropriate. Oh really? Yeah, okay, so talk about that because we were like, it's spelled the same and I was like, oh, I didn't know this. It's true. So are we supposed to think
that it's both appropriate and appropriate? Well, I think at the beginning of the play, there's that sign, right? That sort of drop in front of the curtain that describes all of the various ways in which- The noun and the verb. Yeah, the noun and the verb. What is Will doing?
Hi, Sarah. Hi, how are you? He's working on his smartphone. Well, we don't really know you. No, I got some notification to verify that it's me on my Google. I don't know, but I was listening and what I was thinking was.
I mean, just exactly what we talked about. At least I listened more than you did when you were going to see her play appropriate. Clearly, thanks Will. Yeah, Will was not a- Both of you guys, you both missed it. I missed seeing the play. Now Sarah, I don't really know you
like these guys do, so hi. Then hush, let us talk. Yeah, go ahead, go ahead. Weirdly, I wanted to talk to Will. I mean, I know you both and I sort of- Great, Sean and I'll take a tight five. More interested in that. Take a tight five. More interested in that. Take a tight five.
But why is it appropriate instead of appropriate? I think appropriate could work just beautifully for that play. I think it could, and I think it's why he offers both options at the beginning of the play, because all of it is applicable, but I think, I did ask him directly, it is appropriate. All right. I think he's wrong.
I think he's wrong. I'm gonna tell him. Wait, so I wanna do, so we went backstage. First of all, go see the play, it's amazing, you're phenomenal in it, especially that last monologue was incredible, you're standing on the stairs and it's like you're Scarlett whatever and you're just like, it's incredible, it's incredible.
Thanks, Sean. It's really, really great. That's very kind of you, Sean. By the way, I love that thing too. People were like, you know, I was talking about it afterwards to friends and that thing about, it's too long to go into what the whole play's about
because it's about a lot of things, but your character with your two brothers go back to the home where your father died and you're sorting out business and you find all of these questionable things in his past, like pictures of things and other stuff that bring up a bunch of questions about your family and your upbringing.
And at the end of the play, I thought it was so profound when you were like, and please fill in the blanks, but you're talking to your two brothers and you're like, I'm the oldest of this family. I got to hold you and watch you and see all of the things that create your memories, but nobody's ever held me
or was there for me that was dead. Nobody's left in the family who's done that for me. For me, yeah, that was really powerful. Yeah. Well, it seems appropriate. Oh, God. It's definitely not appropriate. This is why we hired Will.
Well, definitely not, well, because that's a completely different meaning. No, I mean, Jason has a lot of skills, but this one particular assessment is not one of them. I tell you what, do yourself a favor. Don't ask either of them to define it because it'll be embarrassing for everybody. So moving forward. I want to talk about flying and your fear of flying, like why that is a view.
Sorry, before we move beyond the play, Will, are you going to find some time to come see the play? Yeah. I am. I am going to see the play. I had, I had, I was. What's the date, what's the date on that? Just so Sarah can be ready. You know, I hate knowing when people are out there.
So don't tell me, don't. Just give her a ballpark. I'd say it, but she hates knowing. Yeah. All right. I wanted to, cause I was gonna say, I was about to tell you, and then she's like, I hate knowing.
You've got till June 23rd, buddy, but I don't wanna know. I don't wanna know. You know, I don't like to know what, I'm the same way. I don't like to know when people are coming. I don't care if it's your dry cleaner. I don't care if it's your dry cleaner I don't care if it's your dentist. I end up thinking too much about about whether or not there
It's my codependent my kind of hyper vigilant way of listening in the world. I'm just yeah I'm just wondering like even any of my castmates. I don't want to know if your fourth grade teacher was there I'm not gonna say I don't I don't want to know if you're in the play tonight This is how I ended up with three kids. Because people didn't wanna know when I was coming. Listen, let me tell you something, Sarah. Hey, whoa. Let me tell you something, Sarah.
That's terrible. Ding-a-ling-a-ling-dong. Have you ever? Sarah, let me tell you something. Here's what I'm gonna do. I wanna show you, and I have so much respect for you as an artist, unlike these guys. I do too. Unlike these guys. Here's what I'm gonna do. I wanna show you, and I have so much respect for you as an artist, unlike these guys. I do too.
Unlike these guys. Jason's quiet, by the way. I'm not gonna tell you. I'm not gonna tell you when I'm gonna come to see this show. I'm not gonna come and see the show, and I'm not gonna tell you afterwards. So you won't even know I was there. You just say it, yeah.
Okay? Because I respect you. That works for me. Sarah, how I respect you. That works. Because I respect you. That works for me. Sarah, how is that at the end where, you know, for Tracy in Wisconsin, it is a practice, a habit, an obligation for anyone in the audience who knows a cast member, or even if you don't know them,
you just happen to be famous. Jason's obsessed with this. You are obligated to go backstage and introduce yourself to the cast and visit for a bit. And if you don't, apparently that's tantamount to giving it a bad review. And so how do you like that dance there at the end where you're done with the play, you're exhausted,
and now you gotta socialize? It's not my favorite, although I will tell you, we've had a couple of fancy famouses come and not come backstage. And we all collectively discuss that we think it means that they didn't like it. But then we sort of think, well, think about it this way. So you're so famous you think somehow that the cast, whom you do not know, wants you to come backstage
and announce yourself to bequeath them with your great... It's arrogant. It's so weird, so it's that, there's no way to win. Yeah, you can't win. But we have had discussions about, you know, there was like some fancy person who came who had worked with someone in the play who didn't come back, and it was like,
well, no, that is a communication that they just don't like you. Yeah, yeah. Right? So can I ask you, if I... Maybe not the whole play, just you. Yeah. If before June 23rd, I find myself at the Tabasco Theater,
and I've seen the play and I've enjoyed it, and I'm the first one to my feet, and my hands hurt from all the clapping, and I'm hooting and hollering, and then there's the moment. If you guys find out that I'm there and I don't come backstage, do you and your cast want me there?
And there's a thumbs up, I just wanna really make a point of this. Do you guys, do you and your cast, do you guys want me there? Or do you? Yeah, I think we would discuss that we thought Will Arnett didn't like the play. Really?
That's what we would discuss, yeah. What if he didn't like the play? This is all I want, so. This is my moment. What ifett didn't like the play. That's what we would discuss, yeah. What if he didn't like the play? This is all I want, so this is my moment. What if he doesn't like the play and he comes backstage and he lets you know? He thinks he's got helpful notes for you. He says, yeah, yeah, no, I enjoyed it. However, like, has anyone come back there
and popped off about how you can make it fucking better? That has not happened, although I would kind of welcome it actually, just simply so I could discuss it with other people about the outrage. I did do a play once. I will tell you, I did do a play once. My last time I was on stage, I did a play called Tally's Folly at the roundabout. And thank you for the applause. And the actress, and I'm going to say this, and I'm not going to ask you to cut this out because I don't fucking care. This actress came for the applause. And the actress, and I'm gonna say this, and I'm not gonna ask you to cut this out
because I don't fucking care. This actress came to the play. What's her fucking name? Her name is Trish Hawkins. Hi Trish. Hi Trisha. Hi Trish. Trish Hawkins came to this play. Am I gonna get sued?
I don't care, because I think this is outrageous. She came to the play. If it's true. And I proceeded, my mother brought her to the play. They were in some kind of like writing group together. And my mother thought it'd be great to bring Trish Hawkins to the play. I mean, this is a whole other conversation about my mom.
Hi, mom. But she came to the play, proceeded to say, she looked at me and sort of up and down, and then she went, "'Your dress is yellow, mine was pink.'" And I thought, what? What? She did the character before you.
Cut to two days later, I got an email that was six pages long of notes and a communication to me about what she had done when she had done the play. Oh my God. Jesus Christ. What she recommended I do. Oh my God. It was outrageous.
Oh my God. It was really outrageous. Trish Hawkins, I have not forgotten it and I hope to see you never. That's all I have to say. Do you still have the letter? I have it, I do have it. And did you talk to your mother and say please delete her numbers?
I didn't, I sort of just put it back in the file of things my mother has done. That's good though, you need to save that. Sarah, Sarah, can I just say, I need to say something. I need an interject, if you don't mind. Yeah, okay. I don't know you as well as these guys and I have a real feeling that you and I are gonna be
better friends than they could ever imagine. I love you for saying that so fucking much. Oh, yeah. The respect. No, you two would be inseparable. Sarah, I have all the time when people, and when they fucking deserve it. Now, by the way.
I'm like, this is the deal. You cannot come to, you wanna, if you're my dearest friend and we go have a cocktail or a little bread basket, Jason, or some air that we might eat, Jason, but post the show, some air, you might eat some air. Air is so tasty, sounds like Dr. Show, though, it's really wild how good it can be.
But if you are a person that I love and admire, and I say to you, tell me what you thought, really. And give me some, especially like early days previews or something, they're gonna be some real help. Okay, so here it is. So at the top of the show. But I would say this for Trish, I will say this for Trish, Sarah. We have, Sean, you're here.
Trish is here, by the way. Trish is over here. She's still in your guest house, right? Yeah, my mom will probably trot her out. Try to bring her to the next play. By the way, oh, Sarah, I also have a mom who says a lot of inappropriate stuff. I'm just like, mom, what are you doing? Well, we all do.
My mom also, my mom's gonna get so upset about this, but like, Cate Blanchett came to the play the same night that my mother came, same afternoon that my mother came, and Margot Martindale came also, and all these people I love, and I have long relationships with, and I've worked with Kate three times,
I've worked with Margo more than once. And I, of course, was really happy to see them, and I was, I'm not saying I wasn't happy to see my mom, but it was like, maybe the range was a little like, oh my God, Kate, oh my God, Margo, and it was like, hey mom. Hey mom. You know, it was like.
And she didn't like that? And I don't think she loved it, and I think her retribution is to just give me a little less than I would hope for. Yeah, no. Because I think I'm giving her, it's just gotta keep me a little, yeah. And she was like, I mean, I know we're supposed to go out,
I don't know why I'm making my mom sound like this grand dame of Fifth Avenue or something, she's really like the grand dame of Woodstock. She's like a tambourine playing I mean, I'm really sorry. I'm just disparaging you for my own comedy Interest but it's reality. It's my reality. I'm allowed to talk about my reality, right? Yeah I can't Hawkins my mom they belong to and poor Trish or Trish Trish used to love smartless She's every week. She loved it.
And I tell you what, she's about 25 million listeners per month. Trish is about to get the bombardment she never knew she had. She deserves, by the way. The one she deserves. She brought it on. She's a fucking persona non grata. I'll put that email on Instagram faster
than you can say Trish Hawkins. We're gonna put it in the chat. Oh, God. And we will be right back. SmartList is supported by Liquid IV. So guys, summer's coming, it's going to get hot, hot, hot. I know, just walking out the door, it's just getting hotter. So I always make sure I leave my house with a packet of Liquid IV wherever I'm going.
No matter what everyday summer activity you're up to, liquid IV is here to keep you extraordinarily hydrated. With three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink plus eight vitamins and nutrients in a single stick, it's clear why liquid IV is the number one powdered hydration brand in America. One stick and 16 ounces of water hydrates better than water alone. Like for me, when I'm driving my car, I always leave one in my car with a bottle of water. And if I'm driving around for too long,
because I live in LA, so it's a lot of driving, and it gets too hot, I just pour one in there and drink it as I'm driving. It's like the best car ride drink ever. Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration with Liquid IV. Get 20% off your first order of Liquid IV when you go to liquidiv.com
and use code SMARTLESS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when Liquid IV when you go to liquidiv.com and use code SMARTLESS at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop Better Hydration today using promo code SMARTLESS at liquidiv.com. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I know we live in a time where there's a lot of divisiveness not only in our country but in the world. There's so many topics that are seemingly dividing us and it can weigh down on you a lot. A lot of people internalize all of that stuff. I know I do sometimes.
And we all carry around different stressors, big and small. When we keep them bottled up, it can start to affect us negatively. Therapy is a safe place and a safe space to get things off your chest and to figure out how to work through whatever's weighing you down. It's important to check in with yourself and listen to what your body and mind is telling you.
A therapist can help you recognize triggers or signs of burnout so you stay in touch with what you need. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Get it off your chest with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month.
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. You may have heard the quote, "'Good things come to those who wait, but that's only part of the quote. The full quote is actually good things come to those who wait, but only the things left by those who hustle. I love that. Well, if you're a business owner and want the best people on your team, the same applies.
Thankfully, ZipRecruiter puts the hustle in your hiring so you find qualified candidates fast. And now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. As soon as you post your job, ZipRecruiter jumps into action and uses their matching technology to show you qualified people. They make it easy to find the right candidate. Let ZipRecruiter give you the hiring hustle you need. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis to try it for first day. Just go to ziprecruiter.com slash smartless to try it for free. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. All right, back to the show. Sarah Paulson, I want to talk about the fear of flying. You're my hero. Can I just say you're my hero? And you haven't even gotten into your shared fear of flying. Oh you have this too. Yeah yeah of course. Oh god so we're best friends. When's your birthday? Hate to be, not to be too Amanda Anka about it, but when's your birthday? Yeah so god we're even
better friends. May 4th. May 4th. May 4th yeah. Okay. Fourth of May. All right so it's coming up. What sign is that? I just want to know what your sign is. Taurus. Taurus. And what's your rising? Do we know what you're rising? What sign is that? I just wanna know what your sign is. Taurus, I mean Taurus. And what's your rising? Do we know what your rising is? What's your rising? Gemini.
Oh, yeah. What's your moon? I'm a Sagittarius with a Virgo rising and an Aquarius moon, so, you know, do with that what you will. And you believe in all that stuff. I don't. I mean, I don't know enough about it to.
I do kind of think it's a thing, but anyway, the fear of flying is very real for me. There's a lot of weeping that happens if there's a tiny pocket of, like. Really? You'll go right into, right into the weeping. The grabbing the stranger next to me. I know you guys haven't been on a commercial airplane
in a very long time, but if you do do. That's not true. I was on a falcon last week. Is that not He doesn't like the Falcons Falcons he thinks are beneath them The pilot planes are even scarier to me. I don't enjoy it I don't enjoy it
More room for us Sarah Sarah Sarah I want to talk so you yeah, here's here's my thing about pilots And I love hearing that you like to meet the pilot before what I do is I like to say the pilots What how we looking, right, for our journey, because what I don't enjoy is if you get on a flight and you have a bunch of turbulence and the pilot doesn't say, he doesn't come over. Correct, if it's the lack of communication,
I can't stand it. Just go, hey, we got some, it's run-of-the-mill turbulence, it's not a big deal, we're all good, we're blah, blah, blah. But you know, but Sarah, do you have this too, because I have a little bit of this too, the second you hear that, and right not a big deal, we're all good, we're blah, blah, blah, blah. Then I'm good. But Sarah, do you have this too? Because I have a little bit of this too. The second you hear that, and right before the pilot speaks, you're like, oh Jesus, what is this gonna be?
Just the thought of it makes me sweat. Like true. They should come on beforehand, right? We've got some bumps coming up. If they come on and they give you a lay of the land, which is why I like to talk to them, because I say the same thing, how are we looking? They often pull up the iPad with the root,
and they show me where the pockets of potential weather They show this is there on Delta United. I like it. I like Delta You know what it is, you know why cuz you know what it is this communicate This is a relationship and in the relationships really work with communication. So you need to have this communication You can't grow up Sean Sean, for a second, then take five, okay? Because Sarah and I are talking about relationships. Take a tight five.
You're back on a tight five. Sarah, why don't you invite... But wait a second, when's the last time you had a bunch of passengers stop by the cockpit and ask for... No, but Jason, when you walk on, the cockpit's open, it's right there. But if everybody stopped and asked to look at the iPad
for the routing... I'm not asking to look at the iPad, I'm asking how we're doing. And they often pull out the iPad as a way of saying, here's what we're doing. I ask them how the plane looks, who did the checkout, like who went around and checked out the plane. I wanna know how long they've been flying.
I wanna know. Do you ask for a little hint as to what chair the Marshal's sitting in just for fun? Sometimes I've done that. What if it's Sarah, what if you're like, how long have you been flying? It's some 20-year-old, he's like, I'm just flown for one week. Today's day one!
Well I want you to know that it's literally every single pilot joke that is made to me every time I ask him, like, oh, today's my first day. I'm like, not funny at all. Wish me luck, I just was lobotomized. Yeah, and sometimes there are, you know, the young co-pilot has fewer years and fewer hours. How about this, how about I don't like to meet the pilots
because if I meet the pilots, it becomes too human to me and I don't like to imagine the fact that a human being is even possible. This is more of a human than it does not fly. I like to think that there are super human, intelligent people up there that wouldn't even spend a minute with me. Like they're doing adult work up there.
因为如果我见到了飞行员，这对我来说就太有人的气息了，我不愿想象人类竟然能做到这一点。这比不飞行的普通人更像超人。我喜欢想象那些超凡脱智的人在高空，他们甚至不会花一分钟时间陪我。就像他们在高空做成年人的工作一样。
He sits down, he sits in a seat and he plugs a type C plug into the side of his head and it goes into the side of the plane and then he just. Power down. He started speaking. Don't power down, Jason. Exchange information. Just like a software.
他坐下来，他坐在座位上，把一个C型插头插进自己脑侧，然后插进飞机的侧面，接着他就。断电了。他开始说话了。别断电，杰森。交换信息。就像软件一样。
In five hours. So Sarah, are you also a type of gal likes to chat with the Uber driver? Nope, don't wanna talk to the Uber driver. You have that already clicked on your profile there, no cheating chats? Oh no, I did see that but I thought that was rude. To click on it to make a point of it?
在五个小时内。那么，莎拉，你也是那种喜欢跟优步司机聊天的类型吗？不，不想跟优步司机聊天。你已经在你的个人资料里勾选过这个了吧，没有恶作剧聊天吧？哦，不，我确实看到了，但我以为那样很粗鲁。勾选它来表明态度？
To click on it to make it like a rule for them. I'd rather just let my behavior and my demeanor communicate. So if you got on the Uber and the guy started asking you a question, you would just stop him and say, check my profile, right? Well yeah, no exactly. Think about the kind of vibe you gotta kick out to him to get him to be quiet is more rude than him being pre-warned
勾选它就像是给他们定下规矩。我宁愿让我的行为和举止来表达。所以如果你上了优步，司机开始问你问题，你就会直接打断他，说，看看我的个人资料，对吧？好吧，不，完全不是。想想看，你得释放出什么样的气场才能让他闭嘴，这其实比他被预先警告
that this person's not up for a conversation. I guess I think I feel really uncomfortable in general in a car where someone's driving. I have to chat senselessly just to make. What if there was a box for SmartList and you just checked it, I'd rather not chat today. So wait. If they tried talking to me, I was,
这个人不想聊天还要粗鲁。我想，一般来说，当别人在开车时，我在车里总是感到非常不自在。我得毫无意义地聊天只是为了……如果SmartList有个选项，你勾选一下“今天我不想聊天”呢？等等。如果他们试图跟我说话，我会，
they always go, why won't you, and I just go, sorry man, my leprosy is flaring up. You know what I mean? And that gets them quiet. So I love this stuff, And I just go, sorry man, my leprosy is flaring up. You know what I mean? And that gets in quiet. So I love this stuff, because you're not only afraid of flying, but clowns, sharks, bees, and then you have,
他们总是问，你为什么不……然后我就说，对不起，老兄，我的麻风病正在发作。你知道我的意思吗？这样他们就不说话了。所以我就喜欢这样。然后我就说，对不起，老兄，我的麻风病正在发作。你知道我的意思吗？这样他们就不说话了。所以我就喜欢这样，因为你不仅恐高，还怕小丑、鲨鱼、蜜蜂，然后你还有，
what is it, trypophobia? I have that trypophobia thing where I can't, I don't actually know how it's pronounced, like Jason doesn't know about appropriate appropriate, but it's trypophobia, trypophobia, I don't know. But it's, it's like, so it's probably tryp, it's probably, no, it's not fear of tryptophan.
那叫什么来着，密集恐惧症？我有那种密集恐惧症，我其实不知道该怎么发音，就像杰森不知道该怎么读“appropriate”（适当的）一样，但它是密集恐惧症，密集恐惧症，我不知道。但这，这就像是，所以可能是密集，可能是，不，不是对色氨酸的恐惧。
It's fear of holes, it's fear of like. Holes. So like if, holes. Like a group of holes, right? So like if you, like a grouping, a whole grouping. I've heard of this before. Like a natural sponge makes me like actually, I have to, or a coral reef, not interesting.
是对洞的恐惧，对那种……洞的恐惧。所以就像是，洞。像是一群洞，对吧？所以如果你，就像是一个集群，一整群。我以前听说过这个。像天然海绵让我觉得实际上，我不得不，或者珊瑚礁，没兴趣。
Wow, what about an English muffin? No, it's not. Those are nooks and crannies, those aren't holes. Those are nooks and crannies, those are nooks and crannies, Sean. Swiss cheese wrecks your night? No, because they're not close enough together, it's about when they're packed tight.
哇，那英式松饼呢？不，不是。那是凹槽和缝隙，那些不是洞。那是凹槽和缝隙，那是凹槽和缝隙，肖恩。瑞士奶酪会毁了你的夜晚？不，因为它们的洞不够密集，只有当它们紧紧挤在一起时才会这样。
Right, so a loofah, no thank you. I don't like a loofah at all. So what's the reaction? It makes me, it makes my skin crawl and I have to like, I have to run away. And Ryan Murphy decided that this was so funny that he decided to make a season of American Horror Story about a character that I played who had this disorder.
对吧，所以浴球，不用了。我一点也不喜欢浴球。那有什么反应呢？它让我，让我的头皮发麻，我不得不，我不得不逃跑。而瑞安·墨菲觉得这太搞笑了，于是他决定拍一季《美国恐怖故事》，讲一个我演的角色患有这种疾病。
So then I was constantly all day long having to look at these things and run from them, clowns as well and things. That sounds like bullying. That sounds like bullying. Exactly. Did that get you past your fears or did it make it worse? It just, it kept it at a steady place.
所以整天我都在不停地看着这些东西并从它们身边逃跑，还有小丑之类的东西。这听起来像是在霸凌。这听起来像是在霸凌。确实如此。这帮你克服了恐惧，还是让情况变得更糟了？它只是，让它保持在一个平稳的状态。
I'm not. It kept it on high. But the B thing, you know, I've never been, not to bring up my mother again, but my mom. That's what this is about. She locked me outside. She deserves it. to bring up my mother again, but my mom. You know, that's what this is about. She locked me outside. She deserves it. One day, my mother determined that the bees
我不是。它让它一直处于高度紧张状态。但关于蜜蜂这件事，你知道，我从来没有——不是想再次提起我妈妈，但，我妈。这就是这期节目的主题。她把我锁在门外。她活该。再次提起我妈妈，但，我妈。你知道，这就是这期节目的主题。她把我锁在门外。她活该。有一天，我妈妈认定蜜蜂
should be something I should get comfortable with because obviously they do a lot for our planet, they're wonderful, they're great. I had never been stung when I was, yeah, exactly. Dirty hippie. And so I had not been stung at that point and I still at the ripe old age of 49 Have not been stung by a bee because I will drop a baby. I'm not kidding
应该是我能够坦然面对的东西，因为显然它们对我们的星球贡献很大，它们很棒，它们非常了不起。我以前从来没被蛰过，当我，对，没错。肮脏的嬉皮士。所以在那个时候我还没被蛰过，而且到了49岁的大好年龄，我依然没有被蜜蜂蛰过，因为我会把婴儿摔了。我没开玩笑
I will I will drop a baby a tiny baby and fly to a bee. I'm not kidding I cannot be afraid of bees. I'm really you are not are you really? Oh, yeah, I really don't it's my kryptonite I'm allergic. Have you been stung though? I've been stung twice I think. Not allergic. I think I might be making it into something that is, or I'm actually deathly allergic and it's my, you know. No, mine's gotten less as I've gotten older. But the thing for me is that you can't feel them
我会的，我会把一个婴儿、一个极小的婴儿扔出去，然后飞奔去躲蜜蜂。我没开玩笑，我就是很怕蜜蜂。真的吗，你真的很怕？哦，对，我真的很怕，这是我的软肋，我对它过敏。不过你被蛰过吗？我想我被蛰过两次。没有过敏。我想我可能把这事夸大了，或者我其实是对其严重过敏，你知道的。不，随着年龄增长，我的反应没那么强烈了。但对我的问题是，你感觉不到它们
when they land on you. And so the shock of the sting is just gonna come out of nowhere as opposed to, you know, if I'm in a fight with a bee and he gets better at me, then I'm not gonna be, you know, I'm gonna get stung. What if you had super tiny boxing gloves on and they did too and you're just like.
落在你身上。所以被蛰的震惊会突如其来，而不是像，你知道的，如果我和一只蜜蜂在搏斗，它来叮我，那我就不会，你知道的，我肯定会被蛰。如果你戴着超小号的拳击手套，它们也戴着，然后你们就好像……
God, that's a great idea, Sean, you stupid fucking dick. This is a... You guys wanna hear my ultimate kink? My ultimate fantasy? I do. Uh oh, here we go. Oh boy. I'm getting stung by a bee while I'm sitting on a big sponge going through turbulence.
天哪，这主意太棒了，肖恩，你这个蠢货。这是一个……你们想听我的终极癖好吗？我的终极幻想？我想听。哦噢，来吧。哦天哪。我坐在一个大海绵上经历湍流时被蜜蜂蛰。
With clowns going through turbulence. With a clown pilot. With a clown for a pilot. How we look at it? Pretty good. Wee! Wee! Woop woop! He's a clown for a pilot. Yeah, you go up there and you go, how we looking? He goes, pretty good, whee, whee. Whee, whee, whee, whee, whee. Whoop, whoop, whoop. All right, Sean, start your fucking questions.
跟小丑一起经历湍流。和一个小丑飞行员在一起。和一个小丑当飞行员。我们看起来怎么样？挺好的。呜！呜！噢噢！他是个小丑飞行员。对，你走到驾驶舱说，情况怎么样？他说，挺好的，whee，whee。Whee，whee，whee，whee。噢，噢，噢。好了，肖恩，开始你他妈的提问吧。
I got some. I got some. We're 40 minutes into this thing you haven't asked her a question yet. Yeah, and you still have one question that Michael Carey wrote for you. You've got nothing. You need to talk about clowns.
我有一些。我有一些。我们都进行40分钟了，你还没问她一个问题呢。对，你还有一个迈克尔·凯瑞为你写的问题没问呢。你什么准备都没有。你得聊聊小丑。
But I like this stuff more interesting because everybody knows who you are, everybody knows your work, and I wanna talk about that, but I wanna talk about your tattoos first because you have a lot of them, and I wanna know, I did not know this. You have a little freak on your hands, huh?
但我更喜欢聊这些有趣的事，因为每个人都知道你是谁，每个人都知道你的作品，我想聊聊那些，但我想先聊聊你的纹身，因为你有很多纹身，我想知道，我以前不知道。你手上有一个小怪胎，对吧？
I like a lot of tattoos in all kinds of places. She's all tatted up. I got them tattooed everywhere. I was just saying yesterday, I was just saying, nothing says don't hire me like a neck tattoo Yeah, well she doesn't have them on the neck I have one on the back of my neck. Oh, yeah, it's the face forward It's the face tattoos and the neck tattoos is like and I'm sure there people like you look at like the comments like Neck tattoo saved my life, I don't care, but.
我喜欢在各种地方弄很多纹身。她浑身都是纹身。我到处都纹了。我昨天刚说过，我刚说过，没有什么比脖子上的纹身更能表达“别雇我”了。好吧，她脖子上可没有我脖子后面有一个。哦，对，那是正面的，面部纹身和脖子上的纹身就像是，我敢肯定有些人看到评论会说“脖子上的纹身救了我的命”，我不在乎，但是。
Yeah, neck tattoo saved my life. Believe me. But on your right forearm it says, I love this, this is Steven Sondheim lyrics. I know that Jason's gonna make fun of this. Okay, but I love it because I love this. Does it say I'm just a storyteller? No, but it's not, it's not not that.
对，脖子上的纹身救了我的命。相信我。但在你的右前臂上写着，我喜欢这个，这是斯蒂芬·桑德海姆的歌词。我知道杰森要拿这个开玩笑了。好吧，但我喜欢它，因为我喜欢这个。上面写着“我只是个讲故事的人”吗？不，但也不是绝对不是。
You're safe. You wanna say what it is? You wanna say it to say I want to say it because I love it It's from it's from Sunday in the park with George right five six seven eight anything you do Anything you do let it come from you then it will be new Yeah, see Jason it. I love it. His mouth is a guy. Can I punch it up a little bit? Is it too late?
你安全了。你想说是什么吗？你想说出来吗？我想说，因为我太喜欢了。它是从，它是从《公园里的星期天与乔治》里来的，对，五六七八。无论你做什么，无论你做什么，让它发自于你，这样它才会是崭新的。对，看吧，杰森，我太喜欢了。他的嘴像个……我能稍微修饰一下吗？现在太晚了吗？
Well, he's dead, so he might have an opinion. No, it's not temporary. It's on the box. I like it. I really like it. Can I, you could add to it? You could do, and then. I could add to it,
好吧，他已经去世了，所以他可能还会有意见。不，这不是暂时的。它就在那个盒子里。我喜欢它。我真的很喜欢。我能，你还能往上加内容？你可以加上然后……我可以往上加，
but there was actually a line that I took out of it because I thought it was too pompous. What's that? What was it? Which was give them more to see as if I could do something like that. So how would the quote have been? It would have been anything you do,
但其实有一句台词我把它去掉了，因为我觉得它太自命不凡了。是什么？是什么来着？就是“给他们更多可看的东西”，就好像我能做出那种事一样。那原本的引言是怎么样的？原本是：无论你做什么，
let it come from you, then it will be new, give them more to see. This is a musical about George Surratt, the painter, Mandy Patinkin played, Bernadette Peters did, and it's basically her singing to him, it's from a song called Move On. Get out of your sort of, get out of your artistic rut.
让它发自于你，这样它才会是崭新的，给他们更多可看的东西。这是一部关于画家乔治·修拉的音乐剧，曼迪·帕廷金演的，伯纳黛特·彼得斯演的，基本上是她对着他唱歌，出自一首叫《向前走》的歌。跳出你那种，跳出你的艺术瓶颈。
That's nice. If you wanna sort of take away a little bit so it doesn't seem too pop is you could just put comma JK. You know what I mean? Could you imagine that? All right, let's get into Sarah Paulson and how you started and I want to know like Sarah, I'm so sorry about your decision to be with us. Yeah, yeah. Florida, right?
真不错。如果你想稍微删减一点，免得显得太自命不凡，你可以加个逗号，写“开玩笑的”。你知道我的意思吗？你能想象那个画面吗？好了，我们来谈谈莎拉·保尔森以及你是怎么入行的，我想知道，莎拉，非常抱歉你决定和我们在一起。对，对。佛罗里达，对吧？
We're in Florida, Tampa, Florida. You were born. How old were you when you moved to Maine? Born in Tampa, Florida. We moved to Maine when I was in the, how old were you in the second grade? Seven. Seven. So I moved there in second grade.
我们在佛罗里达，坦帕，佛罗里达。你出生在那里。你搬到缅因州时几岁？出生在佛罗里达州坦帕。我在上，你上二年级时几岁？我们搬到缅因州时你几岁？七岁。七岁。所以我是在二年级时搬到那里的。
But we moved to New York first. It was New York when I was five. And then Maine and then back to New York? And then Maine and then I went back to Florida and then back to New York where I moved a lot of places. My mom was a young mom. This is fascinating. Your mom worked at Sardis on Broadway,
但我们先搬去了纽约。我五岁时在纽约。然后是缅因州，然后又搬回佛罗里达，接着又回纽约，我搬过很多地方。我妈妈是个年轻妈妈。这太迷人了。你妈妈曾在百老汇的萨迪斯餐厅工作，
which is right next to the Hayes Theater. That was her first job when she moved to New York. That's crazy, wow. Was working at Sardis. I mean, was she an actress as well? No, a writer. Oh wow. And she was a young mom?
就在海斯剧院旁边。那是她搬到纽约后的第一份工作。太疯狂了，哇。在萨迪斯工作。我的意思是，她也是个演员吗？不，是个作家。哦，哇。而且她是个年轻妈妈？
21, she had me at 21 and my sister at 23. So you know, we can kind of forgive the Trish Hawkins situation because she just doesn't know what to do. Trish and your mom are just in the picture. And daddy, if you don't mind me asking, in the picture, out of the picture? No, in the picture, still in Florida.
21岁，她21岁生了我，23岁生了我妹妹。所以你知道的，我们某种程度上可以原谅崔茜·霍金斯的情况，因为她当时根本不知道该怎么做。崔茜和你的妈妈都在照片里。还有爸爸，如果我冒昧问一下，还在照片里吗，还是已经不在了？不，还在照片里，依然在佛罗里达。
Really? You know? Were they ever married? They were married. They were married very briefly. Divorced by the time I was two and my sister was 10 months old. Still could have been your fault though, sorry.
真的吗？你知道吗？他们结过婚吗？他们结过婚。他们结过很短时间的婚。在我两岁、我妹妹10个月大的时候就离婚了。不过这也可能是你的错，抱歉。
Yeah, definitely. If you were colicky or something like that. Yeah, he was like, God, this colicky baby, always wanted to sing these Annie songs. Wait, so Sarah, so tell me about that story about your mom singing. Telling me about the story. Telling me about the story. Telling me about the story.
对，绝对是的。如果你当时经常肠绞痛或者什么的。对，他当时会想，天哪，这个肠绞痛的婴儿，总是想唱这些《安妮》的歌。等等，莎拉，跟我讲讲你妈妈唱歌的那个故事。跟我讲讲那个故事。跟我讲讲那个故事。跟我讲讲那个故事。
About your mom seeing a psychic at some point and telling what, and saying what? I knew you were gonna say that. No, your mom, when you were a kid. My mom went to a psychic when some point and telling what? And saying what? I knew you were gonna say that. No, your mom, when you were a kid. My mom went to a psychic when she was, when I guess I was young, and she said something like, you know, your daughter's going to live a really non-traditional life.
关于你妈妈曾经去找过算命先生，然后说了什么？我知道你要这么说。不，你妈妈，当你还是个小孩的时候。我妈妈在某个时候去找过算命先生，然后说了什么？又说了什么？我知道你要这么说。不，你妈妈，当你还是个小孩的时候。我妈妈去找算命先生时，当，我想我当时还很小，算命先生说了一些类似的话，你知道的，你女儿将会过一种非常非传统的生活。
And she's not gonna do things sort of by the book. And did she tell you that's what the psychic said? She told me that, but after I was older and fell in love with a woman, and then she was like, well, I had the psychic tell me that's what the psychic said? She told me that, but after I was older and fell in love with a woman and then she was like, well, I had the psychic tell me that this was gonna happen. Because to her that was sort of living a non-traditional life, which you know. Not the acting part.
她做事不会按部就班。她跟你说过算命先生是这么说的吗？她跟我说过，但那是等我长大后爱上了一个女人，然后她说，嗯，我让算命先生算过，算命先生就是这么说的。她跟我说过，但那是等我长大后爱上了一个女人，然后她说，嗯，我让算命先生算过，说这事会发生。因为对她来说，那算是一种非传统的生活，你知道的。不是演戏那部分。
Not anymore. Not the acting part, yeah, exactly. Not anymore. But you knew at such a young age, because you went to the fame school, fame. Wait, didn't Aniston, didn't Aniston? Aniston went there, yeah, she did. Were you guys in the same class?
不再是了。不是演戏那部分，对，没错。不再是了。但你从那么小就知道，因为你去了那所名气学校，Fame。等等，安妮斯顿，安妮斯顿是不是……安妮斯顿去过那里，对，她去过。你们是同班同学吗？
No. No, she graduated a little Yeah, she did. Were you guys in the same class? No. No, she graduated a little bit before I did. Oh, snap. Oh, snap. We will cut that out. We will cut that out. Are you kidding? Cut it out. We're gonna fucking loop it
不是。不，她毕业得稍微……对，她去过。你们是同班同学吗？不是。不，她毕业得比我早一点。哦，糟了。哦，糟了。我们要把它剪掉。我们要把它剪掉。开玩笑吧？剪掉它。我们要在脑海里不断回放它，
and we're gonna send it to Jen immediately. It's just, these are just the facts. This is not, you know, it's not a, I mean, nobody looks better than Jennifer Aniston. That's a fact. That is a fact. That is a fact. That is a fact. So wait Sarah, so your sister's a casting director, you're an actress, brothers and sisters?
然后立刻发给詹妮弗。这只是，这些都只是事实。这并不是，你知道的，这并不是一个，我的意思是，没有人比詹妮弗·安妮斯顿看起来更好了。这是个事实。这就是个事实。这就是个事实。这就是个事实。所以等等，莎拉，你妹妹是个选角导演，你是个演员，还有其他兄弟姐妹吗？
I have another sister, my dad remarried, I have a half sister named Rachel. We don't know what she does. Okay but why? She actually teaches acting classes that she, I mean I'm literally. Is this true? We can cut the whole episode, okay Sarah? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
我还有另一个妹妹，我爸爸再婚了，我有一个同父异母的妹妹叫雷切尔。我们不知道她是干什么的。好吧，但为什么？她其实教表演课，她，我的意思是，真的吗？这是真的吗？我们可以把整集都剪掉，好吗，莎拉？等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
Everybody's involved. So I moved to LA. There we go. And then my sister, so here's the truth, and everybody has this in a family, I think, to some degree. I mean, I don't know what your stories are, and frankly, I don't care, but I. Don't get me started.
全家人都卷进来了。所以我搬到了洛杉矶。就是这样。然后我妹妹，所以真相是这样的，我想每个家庭多多少少都有点这种事。我的意思是，我不知道你们家里是什么情况，坦白说，我也不在乎，但我……别让我打开话匣子。
My family's normal. But I'm just saying, I wanted to be an actress from the time I feel like when I was in utero. Like it feels like I came out of the womb wanting to do this. My siblings, I think, had more, I think less of a clear idea about what that particular passion was, and are probably better at a lot of things,
我的家庭很正常。但我的意思是，我从感觉自己还在子宫里的时候就想当演员了。就像我一出生就带着这种愿望。而我的兄弟姐妹们，我觉得，对于那种特定的热情没有那么清晰的概念，可能在很多事情上做得比我更好，
whereas I have one thing that I can do. Whereas my sister's great at math and all this other shit that I can't do. You know? But I mean, I don't think it's that strange, is it? Or maybe it is. Like, are all of your siblings, like? None, not one.
而我只会做这一件事。相比之下，我妹妹擅长数学以及所有其他我不会的破事。你知道吗？但我的意思是，我觉得这并不那么奇怪，对吧？或者也许真的很奇怪。听着，你们所有的兄弟姐妹都，比如？一个都没有，一个也没有。
I have three other brothers and a sister. But did they all know what they wanted to be, whatever it was they wanted to do? Did they have that? Well, my sister kind of had a, yeah, my sister did a little bit. She knew she wanted to be a cop. But she was.
我有另外三个兄弟和一个妹妹。但他们都知道自己想成为什么样的人吗，无论他们想做什么？他们也有那种……嗯，我妹妹某种程度上，对，我妹妹稍微有一点。她知道自己想当警察。但她曾是……
Are you kidding? Your sister's a cop? Yeah, she was a cop. And she is a cop. Yeah, well, she was, not anymore. She'll kick your ass. She knew she wanted to be a cop. She was. Are you kidding? Your sister's a cop? Yeah, she was a cop. Well, she was. Not anymore. She'll kick your ass. She was. By the way, Sean's sister, yesterday, I got a... I want to say this to Tracy. Tracy lives in Wisconsin.
你开玩笑吧？你妹妹是个警察？对，她曾是个警察。而且她就是个警察。对，好吧，她曾经是，现在不是了。她会踢你屁股的。她知道自己想当警察。她曾是……你开玩笑吧？你妹妹是个警察？对，她曾是个警察。好吧，她曾经是。现在不是了。她会踢你屁股的。她曾是……顺便说一句，肖恩的妹妹，昨天我收到一个……我想对特雷西说这番话。特雷西住在威斯康星州。
Tracy, listen up. A beautiful red... Beautiful red golf shirt. ... Wisconsin Badgers golf shirt. Which was very generous and very... And with a beautiful note that was so nice. She's a very nice person, Sean. I don't know why she deserves what you're saying
特雷西，听好了。一件漂亮的红色……漂亮的红色高尔夫衫。……一件威斯康星獾队的高尔夫衫。非常慷慨，而且……还附带了一张非常贴心的美丽便条。她是一个非常好的人，肖恩。我不知道为什么她值得你总是
behind the scenes always. She's great, she loves you guys. You've got her wrong. You have her wrong. Tracy is a wonderful person. Anyway, thank you Tracy. You should give her another shot, Sean. Yeah. So, and by the way, Sarah, do you play golf? If you play golf wonderful person. Thank you, Tracy. You should give her another shot, Sean.
在背后这样说她。她很好，她很爱你们。你误解她了。你错怪她了。特雷西是一个非常好的人。总之，谢谢你，特雷西。你应该再给她一次机会，肖恩。对。所以，顺便说一句，莎拉，你打高尔夫吗？如果你打高尔夫的话，是个非常好的人。谢谢你，特雷西。你应该再给她一次机会，肖恩。
So, and by the way, Sarah, do you play golf? If you play golf, my sister sent you a shirt. I don't, I don't play golf. Okay, great, moving on. I still want the shirt, is that bad? Yeah, no, that's okay. I still want it. I sleep in it.
所以，顺便说一句，莎拉，你打高尔夫吗？如果你打高尔夫，我妹妹给你寄了一件衬衫。我不，我不打高尔夫。好吧，太棒了，我们继续。我还想要那件衬衫，这样很糟糕吗？对，不，没关系。我还想要它。我穿着它睡觉。
Okay, great. And now, a word from our sponsor. Hey, smart list listener, we're supported by Mint Mobile. My favorite spring cleaning takeaway is the post-clean clarity you get, right? Wow, how have I been living like this? It's kind of like when you find out that you've been paying a fortune for wireless when Mint Mobile has phone plans for 15 bucks a month when you purchase a three-month plan. Wow, how have I been affording this?
好的，太棒了。现在，听听我们赞助商的话。嘿，SmartList的听众朋友们，我们得到了Mint Mobile的支持。我最喜欢的春季大扫除心得就是打扫完后那种清爽的感觉，对吧？哇，我以前是怎么过这种日子的？这就好比当你发现自己为无线服务花了一大笔冤枉钱，而Mint Mobile的电话套餐在购买三个月套餐时只需每月15美元。哇，我以前是怎么负担得起这个的？
It's time to switch to Mint Mobile and get unlimited talk, text, and data for $15 a month. Say bye-bye to your overpriced wireless plans, jaw-dropping monthly bills, and expected overages. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month unlimited wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to MintMobile.com slash SmartList. That's MintMobile.com slash SmartList. Cut your wireless bill to $15 a month at MintMobile.com slash SmartL. Cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
是时候转投Mint Mobile，享受每月15美元的无限通话、短信和流量了。跟价格虚高的无线套餐、让人惊掉下巴的每月账单以及意料之外的超额费用说拜拜吧。使用你自己的手机搭配任何Mint Mobile套餐，并带上你的电话号码以及所有现有联系人。要获得这项新客户优惠以及只需每月15美元的全新3个月无限无线套餐，请访问MintMobile.com斜杠SmartList。网址是MintMobile.com斜杠SmartList。在MintMobile.com斜杠SmartList将你的无线账单削减至每月15美元。在MintMobile.com斜杠SmartList将你的无线账单削减至每月15美元。
at mintmobile.com slash smartless. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 a month. New customers on first three month plan only. Speed slower above 40 gigabytes on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees, and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. We get support from State Farm. When you get a new car or a new home,
需提前支付45美元，相当于每月15美元。仅限前三个月套餐的新客户。无限套餐使用超过40GB后网速会变慢。需缴纳其他税费并受相关条款限制。详情请查阅Mint Mobile。我们得到了State Farm的支持。当你买了一辆新车或新房时，
your first reaction might be, I can't believe it, or boo-yah. But what you really want to say is the one thing that can get you the help you need. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. State Farm is there with the coverage you need for your car, your home, and even boats, motorcycles, RVs, and other things that matter to you. With a State Farm agent, you know someone is there to help you choose the coverage you need. With so many coverage options, it feels good knowing you can find what fits for you. And when you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. In person or on the phone with your local agent or on statefarm.com or their award-winning app,
你的第一反应可能是“我简直不敢相信”或者“太棒了”。但你真正想说的是那句能为你提供所需帮助的话。就像好邻居一样，State Farm就在身边。State Farm随时为你提供所需的车险、房险，甚至船只、摩托车、房车以及其他对你重要事物的保障。通过State Farm代理人，你知道有人会随时帮你选择你需要的保障。面对如此众多的保障选项，知道能找到最适合自己的方案，这种感觉真好。当需要寻求帮助时，State Farm也为你提供了多种选择。无论是在线下面对面、通过本地代理人电话沟通，还是在statefarm.com或他们屡获殊荣的应用程序上，
State Farm lets you do things your way. So when you need help protecting the things that matter most, remember to say, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Remember to say, like a good wellness, business, and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next-listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog,
State Farm都让你能按自己的方式行事。因此，当你需要帮助保护最重要的事情时，记得说：就像好邻居一样，State Farm就在身边。SmartList由Audible部分赞助呈现。记得说：就像健康、商业等等领域的优质内容一样。Audible是您通往惊险有声娱乐的目的地，这里有备受期待的新发布作品以及为各种惊悚片迷推荐的下一本收听书单。作为Audible会员，您每个月可以从整个目录中选择并永久保留一本书，
including the latest bestsellers and new releases. So I love thrillers, I love thriller movies, and once I found out Audible does thrillers too, I was so excited. So I checked out Thriller, actually, by Heather Graham. And what begins as a simple dog-sitting job for a friend soon becomes the most terrifying night of Riley Jordan's life.
包括最新的畅销书和新发布作品。我非常喜欢惊悚片，我喜欢惊悚电影，一旦我发现Audible也有惊悚片，我简直太兴奋了。所以我查看了由海瑟·格雷厄姆创作的《惊悚》。而这本小说最初只是为朋友做的一个简单的宠物狗看护工作，很快就变成了莱利·乔丹一生中最恐怖的夜晚。
Riley Jordan is the lead character in the book. It's really, really good, it's a great listen. And by the way, the title is inspired by the song of Michael Jackson, which I thought was interesting, but a totally different story, of course. Check it out if you can. New members can try Audible free for 30 days.
莱利·乔丹是书中的主角。真的非常非常棒，非常值得一听。顺便说一句，这个书名灵感来源于迈克尔·杰克逊的歌，我觉得这很有意思，当然这是完全不同的故事了。如果可以的话，去看看吧。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天。
Visit audible.com slash smartlist or text smart list to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smart list or text smart list to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smart list. And now back to the show. So wait, I want to know about Holland, the love of your life. Well, it's wedged just north of Belgium, just south of Denmark, considered part of the Benelux countries. I want to know the fun story because I know a little bit
访问audible.com斜杠smartlist或发送短信smart list到500 500。网址是audible.com斜杠smart list，或者发送短信smart list到500 500即可免费体验Audible 30天，网址是audible.com斜杠smart list。现在回到节目中。等等，我想了解一下荷兰，你一生的挚爱。好吧，它夹在比利时正北方、丹麦正南方，被认为是比荷卢经济联盟国家的一部分。我想听那个有趣的故事，因为我略知一二
of it, but you were at a dinner party and you hoped she wouldn't be sat next to you or something. And then what happened? Yeah, you know, she, I went to know the fun story because I know a little bit of it, but you were at a dinner party and you hoped she wouldn't be sat next to you or something and then what happened? Yeah, you know, she, I went to this dinner party that a friend of mine hosted where it was really kind of for Buck Henry who was there and it was a wild night. And I was at this dinner, it was a long, long table and there was one empty seat and Holland Taylor comes sort of, you know, bustling in and her hair just like throwing her hair back and just, oh God, sorry I'm late,
其中一些，但你当时在一个晚宴上，你希望她不要坐在你旁边什么的。然后发生了什么？对，你知道，她，我想听那个有趣的故事，因为我略知一二其中一些，但你当时在一个晚宴上，你希望她不要坐在你旁边什么的，然后发生了什么？对，你知道，她，我去参加了一个由我朋友主持的晚宴，那场晚宴其实主要是为了巴克·亨利办的，他也去了，那真是一个疯狂的夜晚。我在那场晚宴上，桌子非常非常长，有一个空座位，然后霍兰·泰勒，你知道的，有点风风火火地走了进来，甩着她的头发，然后，噢天哪，抱歉我迟到了，
which, you know, late people, when they're really that late, it does end up making it sort of all about them when they arrive, you know? So she was really doing a like, kind of grand, oh, I'm so sorry I'm late at all. We all, and I looked up and I thought, that is really a very beautiful person. And I found her to be intimidating.
你知道的，迟到的人如果真的迟到得那么厉害，当他们到达时，最终确实会把所有注意力都吸引到自己身上，对吧？所以她当时确实表现得像是在摆出一个隆重的姿态，哦，真的很抱歉我迟到了之类的话。我们所有人都抬头看去，我想，那真的是一个非常漂亮的人。我觉得她很有压迫感。
She's really smart and has a kind of formidable presence. And she's incredibly talented. And I was young at the time, guys. I was 35, 36. Wow. And she sat down next to me and I thought, oh God. And then, you know, we just chatted a little while and then really never saw each other again except for on the back lot where I was doing Studio 60 at Warner Brothers and she
她真的很聪明，有一种令人敬畏的气场。而且她才华横溢。当时我还很年轻，伙计们。我才35、36岁。哇。她在我旁边坐下来，我想，哦天哪。然后，你知道的，我们只是聊了一会儿，之后就再也没见过面，除了在华纳兄弟的后厂景里，当时我在拍《日落大道60号工作室》，而她
was shooting Two and a Half Men. And she rolled her window down and said, hey blondie, do you need a ride? That's what she said to me. Wow. Right. And I was like, oh no. I'm okay. I can walk to stage 19 myself.
在拍《好汉两个半》。她摇下车窗说，嘿，金发妞，要搭便车吗？她就是这么对我的。哇。对。然后我说，噢，不用了。我挺好的。我自己能走到19号摄影棚。
And we never saw each other again. And then we ended up doing a little PSA for Martha Plimpton's abortion. This is not going well, guys. This is not going well. By the way, I know this is the story about how you and Holland got together, but for me, it's the details of it are the fucking meat.
然后我们再也没见过面。后来我们最终为玛莎·普林普顿的堕胎权拍了一则公益广告。这期节目进展不顺利啊，伙计们。这期节目进展不顺利。顺便说一句，我知道这是一个关于你和霍兰如何在一起的故事，但对Fxx我来说，其中的细节才是他妈的精华。
They're really the meat of it. Because the Buck Henry dinner and the Martha Plimpton abortion fucking... This is like the fucking Olympics for me. This is incredible. She has an organization called A is 4, which is an abortion reproductive rights organization, and she asked us to do this PSA. So, Holland and I happened to arrive on the same day. Holland was getting ready to come to New York to do her production of Anne, which she wrote,
那才是最核心的干货。因为巴克·亨利的晚宴和玛莎·普林普顿的堕胎权……这对我来说就像是奥运会一样。这太不可思议了。她有一个名为“A is 4”的组织，这是一个关于堕胎生殖权利的组织，她邀请我们拍摄这则公益广告。所以，我和霍兰恰好在同一天到达。霍兰正准备去纽约排演她自己写的关于安·理查兹州长的戏剧《安》，
that was gonna be done at Lincoln Center about Governor Anne Richards. It was a one-on-one show. That was the prequel to Annie, is it not? Yeah, well, that was probably Annie, like when Annie is finally a grown-up. She grows up. Grows up to be Governor Texas.
这部戏将在林肯中心上演。这是一部独角戏。那是《安妮》的前传，不是吗？对，好吧，那大概是安妮，就像安妮终于长大的时候。她长大了。长大后成为了得克萨斯州州长。
It's a sequel. It was a really hard-knock life before that. Yeah, exactly, hard-knock life. Yeah, and we saw each other there, and then we followed each other on Twitter, and I literally DM'd her when I was shooting in New Orleans. Yeah, I slid into Holland Taylor's DMs. Wow.
这是个续集。在此之前，那真的是一段艰难的生活。对，没错，艰难的生活。对，我们在那里见到了彼此，然后我们在推特上互相关注，当我在新奥尔良拍戏时，我真的给她发了私信。对，我滑入了霍兰·泰勒的私信。哇。
Wow, look at that. And then I sent a picture of her to a friend of mine and I was like, can I date a 70 year old woman? Right. And my friend was like, absolutely not. And I'm just kidding, she was like, yes you can. She was like, fuck no, are you insane? And I was like, I think I'm gonna do it.
哇，看看这个。然后我把她的照片发给我一个朋友，我说，我能和一个70岁的女人约会吗？对。我朋友说，绝对不行。我开玩笑的，她的反应是，可以的。她当时的反应是，他妈的不会吧，你疯了吗？我说，我想我要这么做。
I think I'm gonna fucking do it, why not? And so I did. And you guys have now been together for? And then the rest is history, almost 10 years. Not over nine years. That's so awesome. That's amazing. That's so cool. That's what you say, 19 years?
我想我他妈的要这么做了，为什么不呢？于是我就做了。你们现在已经在一起……然后剩下的就是历史了，快10年了。差不多超过9年了。太棒了。这太惊人了。太酷了。你刚才说什么，19年？
No, nine years. I'm 66. Okay, I don't know. I'm not paying attention. And she's 110. She's 110. She was born. I love being around you guys too.
不，9年。我66岁。好吧，我不知道。我没注意听。她110岁了。她110岁了。她出生于……我也喜欢和你们这些人在一起。
You can just tell how comfy you guys are with each other. That it's one plus one making three. It's just that you're both individuals, but you got the overlap. I mean, it's just perfect. Yeah, we don't live together. That's the sort of secret to it. You know, Sean's married to a man.
你能看出你们彼此是多么的自在。1加1等于3。这就是你们既是独立的个人，但又有着重叠的部分。我的意思是，这太完美了。对，我们不住在一起。这就是其中的秘诀所在。你知道的，肖恩和一个男人结婚了。
I do know that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sure is. They don't sleep together either. No, we don't. Well, I, Holland and I, we spend plenty of time together, but we don't live in the same house. Now talk to me a little bit about that.
我确实知道这一点。对，对，对。当然是。他们也不睡在一起。不，我们没有。好吧，我，我和霍兰，我们有很多时间在一起，但我们不住在同一个房子里。现在跟我聊聊这个。
Are you serious? Because I'm not, tell me about that a little bit about that. Are you serious? Yeah. Tell me about that a little bit. And again, okay, this is, I'm divulging too much, but I said to Alessandra recently, who also, you like her tattoo, she has a lot of great tattoos. Yeah, on her neck, right?
你是认真的吗？因为我不是，跟我稍微聊聊这个。你是认真的吗？对。跟我稍微聊聊这个。再说一次，好吧，这，我透露得有点多，但我最近对亚历山德拉说——她也，你喜欢她的纹身，她有很多很棒的纹身。对，在脖子上，对吧？
No, no, on her neck. On her arms, really cool. She does have one on the back of her neck. And I said to her recently, we started talking about the idea of separate beds. Geez, yeah, great. Which is, and somebody wrote this, not in the same room, somebody wrote this thing,
不，不，在脖子上。在胳膊上，真的很酷。她脖子后面确实有一个。我最近对她说，我们开始谈论分床睡的想法。天哪，对，太棒了。也就是，有人写了这篇文章——不是在同一个房间里，有人写了这件事，
she sent it to, she sent me this article because I kind of joked about it. Because sleep is so important, we're big sleepers, we're 915 and betters. And so, yeah, yeah. And that's why I am 65, and that's why I look so incredible. That's why I look so, in case you confused. And I'm taking the words out of your,
她把它发给，她把这篇文章发给我，因为我曾经开玩笑提起过。因为睡眠太重要了，我们都是很能睡的人，我们晚上9点15分就上床睡觉。所以，对，对。这就是为什么我65岁了，这也是为什么我看起来如此不可思议。这就是为什么我看起来如此……以防你们搞混了。我把你要说的话，
I feel like I'm cutting you off. No, you're venting. No, she didn't say how great you look. Okay, okay. But, sleep in hookers. Keeps you young. No, but we started talking about this idea, and so then we made a joke, and we're not gonna do it,
我觉得我打断你了。不，你在宣泄。不，她可没说你看起来多棒。好吧，好吧。但是，分床睡。能保持年轻。不，但我们开始讨论这个想法，然后我们开玩笑说——我们其实不会这么做，
but this joke about living separately, living in another house, there is a certain wisdom to it on some levels, right? I mean, we've been together for a long time now and I think part of it has to do with we're together when we wanna be and we're not when we don't. Yeah, but couldn't you, but instead of, just challenging it, instead of living in separate dwellings, what about just living together,
但关于分居生活、住在另一所房子里的这个玩笑，从某些层面来看确实有一定的智慧，对吧？我的意思是，我们在一起已经很久了，我想其中一部分原因在于，想在一起的时候就在一起，不想在一起的时候就不在一起。对，但是，难道你不能……与其——换个角度挑战一下，与其住在不同的住所里，为什么不就住在一起，
but then sleeping in separate rooms? No, because my favorite thing to do, we fall asleep holding hands, Holland and I. We sleep holding hands. We're very, I like to sleep near her. I don't want to be around her the rest of the time. Just kidding. Sure, it's the daylight hours.
但晚上睡在不同的房间呢？不，因为我最喜欢做的事，我们睡着时会手拉着手，我和霍兰。我们手拉着手睡觉。我们非常……我喜欢挨着她睡。其余时间我可不想围着她转。开玩笑的。当然，是白天的时间。
It's the daylight hours where I'm like, you can go. No, I mean, I think we both, Holland, before me, had not been in a ton of long-term relationships, whereas Holland is my sort of third, more than five-year relationship. So I tend to do that and have more experience doing that Holland has it. And so her life and to get to be her age and sort
白天的时间我才会觉得，你可以走了。不，我的意思是，我觉得我们俩都是这样，霍兰在我之前，并没有过很多段长期的恋爱关系，而霍兰是我人生中大约第三段超过五年的恋爱关系。所以我倾向于这样做，并且在这方面比霍兰更有经验。所以对她的人生来说，在这个年纪，而且
of not having really cohabitated with someone for a long time I think it was a lot to sort of all of a sudden have me and all my meanness in her space. But if you live separate days you've got something to talk about right? Where in Canada are you from? If you live separate days. Separate days? I think that, you know, like I spend a bunch of time away, as you guys do as well, when you're working, and it's kind of, it's nice to be able to fill your partner in on that which they have not experienced with you.
很长一段时间没有真正和某人同居过，我觉得突然迎来了我和我所有的刻薄脾气进入她的空间，这确实挺不容易的。但如果你分开过日子，你们就有什么好聊的了，对吧？你是加拿大人吗？如果你分开过日子。分开过日子？我觉得，你知道的，就像我花很多时间不在家一样，你们也是，当你们在工作的时候，能够把那些对方没有和你一起经历的事情讲给伴侣听，这其实挺美好的。
It gives you something to fucking talk about. I thought you were gonna go somewhere else with that, but yeah. Honestly, it's one of my favorite things is to come home after a long time and fill my partner in. I was gonna make the same joke, and I just want you to know that that was the joke I was gonna make.
这能给你们提供他妈的聊天话题。我以为你要往别的方向说呢，不过也对。老实说，这是我最喜欢的事情之一，就是在很长一段时间后回到家，向我的伴侣汇报情况。我本来也要开这个玩笑的，我只想让你知道，那就是我原本要开的玩笑。
I knew you were. And I appreciate you will, and I appreciate that I'm not the only one with the mind. Of course not. The size of a tiny pea. Now, what I, 11 year old. Now, Sean, I will recommend to you
我知道你会的。我很感激你会这么想，我也很感激不仅我一个人有这样的脑子。像一颗小豌豆那么大。现在，肖恩，我要向你推荐
something that Amanda and I do, is that we do share the same, Say suicide. We do share the same bed, but we have two different duvets. Therefore, when she rolls over or I roll over, there's not a duvet drag that wakes up the other person. That's great.
我和阿曼达正在做的一件事，那就是我们确实睡在同一张床上，但我们有两条不同的被子。因此，当她翻身或者我翻身时，不会发生扯被子把另一个人弄醒的情况。那太棒了。
But Jay, my thing is snoring. Do you snore or Scottie snores? He could bring down a building. Right. And I... Do what Amanda does, you just slide your hand underneath the shoulder just a little bit, create a little bit of a wedge and they roll over. You get that guy on his stomach and he's not going to snore.
但杰伊，我的问题是打鼾。你打鼾还是斯科蒂打鼾？他打鼾的声音能把一栋楼震塌。对。而我……学学阿曼达的做法，你只要把手稍微伸到他的肩膀底下，制造一点点倾斜，他们就会翻身了。你把那家伙弄成趴着睡，他就不会打鼾了。
What about earplugs? Nobody gets a guy on his stomach like JB. You know what? The snoring is a real thing. And does Scotty have a CPAP machine? Does he sleep with one of those? No, he's going to get it like the newest, the greatest latest. He's going to try it. But he also has what we call the pot of life on his arm because of diabetes.
耳塞呢？没有人能像JB那样把一个家伙弄成趴着睡。你知道吗？打鼾是真事。那斯科蒂有CPAP（持续气道正压通气）呼吸机吗？他睡觉戴那种东西吗？不，他打算弄个最新、最棒的。他会试试的。但他的胳膊上还有我们称之为“生命罐”的东西，因为他有糖尿病。
What's that? Oh, the diabetes. So what, that means he can't roll over? Well, then he's like lying, it's on his shoulder. So then he's like lying on his arm. Hey, do they not have lemon laws in California? What's going on? You still got the receipt on that guy, right?
那是什么？哦，糖尿病。所以，那意味着他不能翻身？好吧，因为他躺着的时候，那东西在肩膀上。所以他就像是压在自己的胳膊上。嘿，加州没有柠檬法（指保护消费者权益的退换货法律）吗？这到底是怎么回事？你还留着那个家伙的发票吧，对吧？
Fuck man! That's really funny. Anything else on the list, Sean? Anything else on my career? Well, let me check in with Will. Will, can I move on to the career or no? Hey, wait. Sarah's not done alienating more people in her personal life. You've got a minute, 20 seconds left to ask a fucking question. Wait, no, what time did we start?
他妈的！这太好笑了。名单上还有别的吗，肖恩？我的职业生涯还有别的吗？好吧，我问问威尔。威尔，我能转到职业生涯这个话题了吗，还是不行？嘿，等等。莎拉还没把她个人生活里更多的人疏远呢。你还有1分钟20秒的时间来问个他妈的问题。等等，不，我们是什么时候开始的？
No, we're just getting started with Sarah. This is, I'm here all day, right? Like I've got a ration of food here. I've got a, yeah. We bought a double book. If you're not, if this interview's over, I'm FaceTiming you, because this cannot end. Wait, I want to know, like,
不，我们才刚刚开始了解莎拉。这，我一整天都在这儿，对吧？就像我在这儿有一份口粮一样。我有一份，对。我们订了双人档。如果你们不……如果这次采访结束了，我要跟你视频通话，因为这不能结束。等等，我想知道，
I was going to go through all your stage stuff, like you did the glass menagerie opposite Jessica Lange. You were in a show with Jessica Lange, that's so amazing. And did Ryan Murphy see that, and that's how he cast you in American Horror Story, or did he see you in something else? Yeah, what's going on with you and Ryan? What kind of stuff do you have on him,
我本来想过一遍你所有的舞台剧作品，比如你跟杰西卡·兰格演过《玻璃动物园》。你跟杰西卡·兰格合作过一档节目，这太了不起了。瑞安·墨菲是看了那个才让你演《美国恐怖故事》的吗，还是他在别的节目里看到了你？对，你和瑞安是怎么回事？你手里有什么关于他的把柄，
and will we ever see? I got nothing on Ryan. Ryan's an open book, man. Everything I got on Ryan, you know about Ryan, you know? You know I've never met him. I'd like to meet him. You've never met him? No, never. I don't think I have either. I met him maybe decades ago.
我们以后还能见到吗？我才没有什么瑞安的把柄。瑞安是个透明人，伙计。关于瑞安我有的所有料，你都知道，你知道的？你知道我从来没见过他。我很想见见他。你从来没见过他？对，从没见过。我想我也没有。我可能几十年前见过他一次。
You're keeping him all to yourself. Why don't you share him with us for Christ's sake? I share him, but I love him. He's, you know, he's been very, very good to me. Like the first person in my working life, I felt who really saw me, you know? Like he continued to say, I'm not, I don't know why I always use sports analogies
你把他全一个人藏起来了看。看在上帝的份上，你为什么不把他跟我们分享一下呢？我分享了，但我爱他。他，你知道的，他对我和非常好。就像在我职业生涯中，他是第一个让我觉得真正被看见的人，你知道吗？就像他一直说，我不知道为什么我总是用体育类比，
when I don't watch any sports, but he continually threw me the ball, just always, and thought I could do things I didn't even know I could do. And so for me, he's just an absolute hero hero in my life both as a friend and a professional. And so you really felt seen? I really felt seen, Will. Yeah. Did you feel?
虽然我根本不看任何体育比赛，但他不断地把球传给我，总是这样，而且觉得我能做到一些连我自己都不知道我能做到的事。所以对我来说，无论作为朋友还是在专业上，他绝对是我生命中的大英雄。所以你真的觉得自己被看见了？我真的觉得自己被看见了，威尔。对。你觉得……
But then like Nicole Wallace in Game Change. Yeah. She was about to make it. Fucking phenomenal. Absolutely incredible in that. Wait, Nicole Wallace? I played Nicole Wallace. The four Nicole Wallace like was the MSNBC, you know. She's my hero. Yeah, Nicole Wallace? I played Nicole Wallace, before Nicole Wallace was the MSNBC. Yeah, she's my hero. Yeah, I played her in Game Changers.
但接着就像《规则改变》里的妮可·华莱士。对。她差点就成功了。Fucking太惊艳了。在里面绝对不可思议。等等，妮可·华莱士？我演过妮可·华莱士。那四个妮可·华莱士就像是MSNBC的，你知道的。她是我的偶像。对，妮可·华莱士？我演过妮可·华莱士，在妮可·华莱士去MSNBC之前。对，她是我的偶像。对，我在《规则改变》里演了她。
You gotta see Sarah play her. She's, unbelievable performance, incredible. What is it? It was when Julianne Moore played Sarah Palin. This was that HBO thing where Ed Harris played McCain and Julianne Moore played Sarah Palin. You literally played Nicole Wallace. I did.
你得看看莎拉是怎么演她的。她，表现太惊人了，难以置信。是什么来着？那是朱丽安·摩尔饰演莎拉·佩林的那个。就是HBO的那部戏，埃德·哈里斯演麦凯恩，朱丽安·摩尔演莎拉·佩林。你竟然真的演了妮可·华莱士。我演了。
No way, did you ever meet her? Oh yeah, oh yeah. Oh, yeah No way. I'm such a big fan of hers. I watch her every single day Yeah, it was a very very traumatic thing that happened. I mean you should watch them that you should watch Sean's right You should watch it's amazing. What's it called game change? Okay He was really traumatized by the whole thing the Sarah Palin thing. It was really yeah. Yeah So much so that she didn't vote for her own candidate. She didn't vote for John She was really traumatized by the whole thing, the Sarah Palin thing. It was really... Yeah, I'll bet. Yeah.
不会吧，你见、过她吗？哦，对，哦，对。哦，对，不会吧。我是她的超级粉丝。我每天都看她的节目。对，那是发生过的一件非常非常痛苦的事。我是说你应该看，你应该看肖恩的对吧。你应该看，太惊人了。那叫什么来着？规则改变？好吧。她对整件事真的留下了心理阴影，关于莎拉·佩林的那件事。真的，对，对。甚至夸张到她都没有给自己支持的候选人投票。她没有投票给——她对整件事真的留下了心理阴影，关于莎拉·佩林的那件事。真的……对，我敢说是的。对。
So much so that she didn't vote for her own candidate. She didn't vote for John. She couldn't vote because of it. Wow. It was really wild. And then when you played Marcia Clark, phenomenal in the O.J. Simpson thing. You know, actually, I've got a couple of notes on that one.
甚至夸张到她都没有给自己支持的候选人投票。她没有投票给约翰。她因为这个都不能投票。哇。真的太疯狂了。然后当你饰演玛西亚·克拉克时，在那个O·J·辛普森的案子里简直绝了。你知道，其实，我对那部剧有几个意见。
You got a couple of notes, you got a couple of notes on that. Yeah, are you guys locked on that? Because if so, I won't give you the notes. Okay, you should probably not, because it's already here. No, you are, I don't, I don't, I think I can safely say you've never sucked.
你对那部剧有几个意见。对，你们对那个意见已决了吗？因为如果是那样的话，我就不提意见了。好吧，你大概还是别提了，因为这已经是既成事实了。不，你是，我不知道，我想我可以有把握地说你从来没演砸过。
Ever, yeah. Never been bad, yeah. I got a couple of things in my closet that I think you'd be like, this wasn't the- Probably on three quarter inch tape, right? Yes. Not even in the days of-
从来没有，对。从来没演不好过，对。我衣柜里有几样东西，你会觉得这可不是——大概是用四分之三英寸的磁带录的吧？是的。甚至都不是在那个——
VHS, VHS. Fucking guys, can I just get a little bit of credit? You gotta go? No, I didn't jump in when I was teed up with sucked in in the closet and I didn't say a fucking thing. Yeah, you didn't do it. I didn't either. I didn't say a fucking, I didn't sat here
VHS，VHS。Fucking各位，我能稍微得到一点认可吗？你要走了吗？不，刚才你们话赶话说到“演砸了”和“衣柜”的时候我都没插嘴，我一句Fucking的话都没说。对，你没说。我也没说。我一句Fucking的话都没说，我就坐在这儿
like a good fucking student. Cheap gay joke, you know? But you were refrained. No, I didn't say anything. Sarah, I read that after the OJ thing, Marcia Clark, you couldn't watch yourself anymore. Is that true and why? Yeah.
像个乖巧的Fucking好学生。低级的同性恋笑话，对吧？但你克制住了。不，我什么都没说。莎拉，我看到报道说，在演完OJ那个案子之后，玛西亚·克拉克，你就再也无法看自己的表演了。这是真的吗？为什么？是的。
What? Yeah, I can't watch myself now. Well, I actually decided to, I think for me the Marcia Clark thing was the first time I had done anything where I felt so much connectivity to Marcia the person and so much, it Marsha the person, and so much, it just was the first time there felt like a real creepy actressy kind of melding
什么？对，我现在都不能看自己。好吧，我其实决定了，我觉得对我和玛西亚·克拉克这件事来说，那是我第一次演一个让我对玛西亚这个人和角色产生如此强烈的情感连接的角色，而且那种感觉，对玛西亚本人，而且那种感觉，这只是第一次让人觉得有一种真正毛骨悚然的、演员式的融合
of like almost like a visitation where you've been sort of embodied by a person you don't know, I mean, how it happened. I'm waiting for your joke, Will, about being embodied by, you don't got one? Okay. He's writing it. He's slow.
就好像是一次灵异附体，你不知怎么就被一个你不认识的人给附身了，我是说，事情就是这样发生的。威尔，我等着你的笑话呢，关于被什么附体，你没有吗？好吧。他在写呢。他反应很慢。
He'll get there, he'll get there. That's okay. It's just an opportunity missed, it's not a big deal. But it was the most connected I ever felt to anything I'd ever done professionally and I thought if I watched this, and also it was in conjunction with the most celebrated I had ever been about my work.
他会想出来的，他会想出来的。没关系。这只是一个错失的机会，没什么大不了的。但这确实是我职业生涯中对扮演过的任何角色感到联系最深的一次，我想如果我看这个，而且这也是我因为自己的工作而获得过最多赞誉的时候。
And so I think I thought if I watch this and everybody thinks it's great and I hate it, I'm gonna sort of ruin my experience that I'm having that has never happened to me before, of feeling really, you know. You know what I mean? Like I just thought I'm gonna go in there with my hypercritical way and tear this apart
所以我想如果我看了这个，所有人觉得棒极了但我却讨厌它，我可能会毁掉我从未经历过的这种美妙体验，那种真正觉得，你懂的。你知道我的意思吗？就像我当时想，我要带着我那极度批判的眼光进去，把它批得体无完肤
and that would be a shame, because this is the first time I feel like anyone's giving a shit about my work or what I'm doing, and so I thought I should try to enjoy it. And then I just kept it, yeah. You should check it out, it's pretty fantastic. All of it. And you should also remember that nobody's gonna be
那可就太遗憾了，因为这是我第一次觉得有人在乎我的工作或者我在做什么，所以我想我应该试着去享受它。然后我就一直这么做了，对。你应该去看看，真的挺棒的。全片都是。而且你也应该记住，没有人会
more critical about your work than Trisha. Trisha Hawkins, I'm surprised I haven't gotten an email from her. If everything that's ever come out, I'm just shocked. So is that still your policy, is to not watch your work? Yes, except for when I have been EP-ing things, I do watch it, but I try to watch it in a kind of, a way where, you know, cause I'm giving notes.
比特里莎对你的工作要求更苛刻。特里莎·霍金斯，我很惊讶我竟然没收到她的邮件。就我出过的所有作品而言，我简直震惊了。所以这依然是你的原则，不看自己的作品？是的，除了当我担任执行制片人（EP）的时候我会看，但我尽量以某种方式去看，你知道的，因为我要提意见。
Well, you're depriving yourself of incredible performances, but that's just me. I have one last thing and then we're all gonna let you go. So Nicole Wallace, Marcia Clark, and then Linda Tripp, crazy transformation, incredible, look, Clark, and then Linda Tripp. Crazy transformation, incredible. You completely disappeared as Linda Tripp. That was, and so are you. I'm watching your career from outside going,
好吧，你这是在剥夺自己欣赏精彩表演的机会，不过这只是我的看法。我还有一个最后的问题，然后我们就放你走。所以，妮可·华莱士、玛西亚·克拉克，然后是琳达·特里普，疯狂的转变，不可思议，看，克拉克，然后是琳达·特里普。疯狂的转变，不可思议。你演琳达·特里普时完全消失在角色里了。那是，而且你也是。我在外面看着你的职业生涯，心想，
oh, she's so phenomenal at playing as a character actress. Is that your go-to comfort zone? I feel like the vanity component of this industry, particularly for women, but for all of us, like I feel so hyper-focused on this shit, the face and the body and the hair and the weight and the thing and the wrinkles and all this shit, that I definitely feel a kind of freedom
哦，她在饰演性格演员方面太惊艳了。这是你的拿手舒适区吗？我觉得这个行业里虚荣的成分，尤其是对女性而言，但对我们所有人来说，比如我觉得自己对这些狗屁事情过度关注——脸、身材、头发、体重、各种细节、皱纹还有所有这些狗屁，以至于我绝对能感觉到一种自由
when I can hide behind these other things, whether it's Marcia's wig or Linda's, the prosthetics to play Linda. I can hide. It's a way of hiding that I think ultimately. She died. She did die, she died right before we started. No way. Really?
当我能躲在这些其他东西后面时，不管是玛西亚的假发还是琳达的，为了扮演琳达所用的假体。我可以躲起来。我认为这终究是一种躲藏的方式。她去世了。她确实去世了，就在我们开拍前不久去世了。不会吧。真的吗？
Yeah. Wow. Wait, Sarah, before we go, I just wanna know, because you're a creature of the theater like I am, super fast, funny, tragic theater story, anything happen either in this play or another one? Funny or tragic theater story? I mean, I don't know if there's a more tragic story
对。哇。等等，莎拉，在我们结束之前，我只是想知道，因为你和我一样是个戏剧迷，快点，说个好笑的或悲剧的戏剧故事，不管是这部剧还是其他别的剧里发生的？好笑的或悲剧的戏剧故事？我是说，我不知道还有什么比
than getting notes from an actress who played a play 30 years ago, but funny that something happened the other. Well, two things happened recently, which is in the play, which you guys saw, we can discuss this later. In the first act of the play, I am having an argument with the black sheep of the family played by Michael Esper.
收到一个30年前演过一部戏的演员的意见更悲剧的故事了，但好笑的事最近确实发生了一件。好吧，最近发生了两件事，就是在剧里，你们看过的，我们可以晚点讨论这个。在剧的第一幕里，我和由迈克尔·埃斯珀饰演的家族里的害群之马有一场争吵。
The great Michael Esper. The great Michael Esper, who I think you were. He's incredible, and he's a great chorus doll. And I leave the room in a big huff, and I'm very upset, and I've just blown up and screamed at everybody. And I leave the stage, I slam the door, and his line is, what happened to her?
伟大的迈克尔·埃斯珀。伟大的迈克尔·埃斯珀，我想你以前也是。他太棒了，而且他是个很棒的合唱团男孩。然后我气冲冲地离开房间，非常沮丧，我刚刚爆发了，对每个人大喊大叫。我离开舞台，砰地关上门，他的台词是：“她怎么了？”
And someone from the balcony went, you. No. No. Oh, it's a balcony for you. People forget it's a place. And then the other thing that happened that was kind of cool the other day, which is I'd never experienced that,
结果楼座（阳台座位）上有人接了一句：“你呗。”不会吧。不会吧。哦，你那是带楼座的剧院。人们都忘了那是个真实场所。然后发生另外一件事也挺有意思的，就是我以前从来没经历过那种事，
and I don't know if you ever have either, Sean, but we had an actress get sick in Act One and then the understudy went on for Act Two. That's never happened, but I've always wondered about that. It was like Days of Our Lives or something where someone was decapitated in season four and in season 10study went on for Act Two. That's never happened, but I've always wondered about that. It was like Days of Our Lives or something where like someone was decapitated in Season Four and in Season Ten they came out with a different case. Did you have to make an announcement or you just did it?
我不知道你们有没有经历过，肖恩，但我们有一位女演员在第一幕生病了，然后替补演员在第二幕上场了。这从来没发生过，但我一直对这种事很好奇。就像《我们的日子》或者别的什么剧里，某个角色在第四季被斩首了，然后在第十季替补演员上场了第二幕。这从来没发生过，但我一直对这种事很好奇。就像《我们的日子》或者别的什么剧里，某个角色在第四季被斩首了，然后在第十季他们换了个演员出场。你们得发公告还是直接就换了？
Yeah. Yeah, they make an announcement and everyone just clapped and there's something very special about the theater where like people are willing to believe anything you do up there as long as you kind of commit to that world. And you like a good pilot, let them know what the fuck is going on. Not to bring it full circle for you guys, but I gotta say.
对。对，他们会发公告，然后大家就鼓掌，戏剧有一种非常特别的魔力，只要你全身心投入那个世界，观众就愿意相信你在台上的任何所作所为。而且就像个优秀的飞行员一样，让他们知道到底发生了什么。虽然不是为了给你们来个首尾呼应，但我必须得说。
That is incredible. It's a relationship between you and the audience. It's a relationship. It's a relationship. You gotta communicate. It's the key to everything, you guys. Listen, lady, early congratulations on your Tony Award. Yes, exactly.
这太不可思议了。这是你和观众之间的一种关系。这是一种关系。这是一种关系。你得进行交流。这是所有事情的关键，伙计们。听着，女士，提前恭喜你获得托尼奖。对，没错。
Incredible performance. We love you and thank you for even showing up today. I love you guys. Will, I just met you, but you're my favorite. I feel the same. Well, that's all the time we have. What a delight, Sarah. I've never been so delighted in my life.
精彩的表演。我们爱你，也谢谢你今天能来。我也爱你们。威尔，我刚认识你，但你是我最喜欢的。我也有同感。好吧，我们的时间就这么多了。太开心了，莎拉。我这辈子从没这么开心过。
Oh my God, thank you. And I really do want you to, also at the Tabasco Theater, Sean, you live on there. I think, have I told you this? First of all, your poster is down in the room. Did you talk about this on the show at all? About the elephant, the room under? The elephant room.
哦天哪，谢谢你们。我真的希望你也能，还有在塔巴斯科剧院，肖恩，你在那儿很有名气。我想，我跟你说过这个吗？首先，你的海报就在后台那个房间里。你在节目里聊过这个吗？关于那个大象房间？大象房间。
The elephant room under the Tabasco Theater. Did you talk about this? Am I boring? Everybody's already talked about it. You say it. But there is, I mean, it's really cool. They call it the elephant room because Houdini, right, used to have this massive room underneath the stage
塔巴斯科剧院下面的大象房间。你们聊过这个吗？我是不是很无聊？大家都已经聊过了。你来说吧。但那里，我是说，真的很酷。他们叫它大象房间，因为胡迪尼，对吧，以前在舞台下方有一个巨大的房间
that could hold an elephant. So part of his magic trick. Because he was going to do a big trick where he was gonna disappear an elephant. Yes, where he raises the elephant from the thing. So they call it the elephant room. Yeah, and so that's down there and there's a big poster of Sean down there.
大到可以容纳一头大象。所以这是他魔术表演的一部分。因为他要表演一个大变大象的魔术。对，他把大象从那个东西下面升上来。所以他们叫它大象房间。对，所以那个房间在下面，而且下面有一张肖恩的大海报。
So you're calling me an elephant. Well I'm just saying, like there are a lot of posters that are not down there. There's two posters down there and yours is one of them. And also every night when I walk backstage to get to my entrance, there is a cork board on the right hand side that the prop guys have up
所以你是说我是大象。我是说，有很多人的海报可没在下面。下面只有两张海报，而你是其中之一。而且每天晚上我走后台去准备上场时，右边有一个布景师挂着的软木板
and it just says Oscar Levant on it. And it's so cool. So I sort of think about you every day when I'm there. I love that, honey, that's very sweet, thank you. And I'm so glad you're there and I'm so glad we saw it and I can't wait to root you on. You're really great. I really appreciate it, you wrote me a lovely text.
上面只写着“奥斯卡·勒凡特”几个字。太酷了。所以我每次在那里都会想到你。我太喜欢了，亲爱的，这太甜了，谢谢。我很高兴你在那里，也很高兴我们去看了演出，我等不及要为你加油了。你真的很棒。我真的很感激，你给我发了一条很温暖的短信。
I didn't hear from you, Jason, but I'm confident I will. Oh, check your spam, no one's in there. I'm confident I will hear from you, Will, when you come backstage or when you don't and then yeah I just had another terrible one. I saw your I want it Please give it get it out and it's fucking killing me And I said that who did he was gonna do that he was gonna do the trick with the elephant It was too long, so they asked him to
我没收到你的消息，杰森，但我确信我会收到的。哦，检查一下你的垃圾邮件，没人被关在里面。我确信我会收到你的消息的，威尔，当你来到后台或者没来的时候，然后，对，我又说了一个糟糕的笑话。我看到你的那个，我想要，请拿出来，这快把我折磨死了。我说那个胡迪尼要做的那个，他要表演那个带大象的魔术。太长了，所以他们让他——
Fuck you guys fuck you Strangely I have to go I mean I just have to go now you gotta rest your voice. I got we love you Thank you guys Goodbye, that was great Thank you guys. Bye honey. Bye. Goodbye. That was great.
Fucking你们，Fucking……奇怪的是我得走了。我是说我真的现在就得走了。你得保护嗓音。我们爱你。谢谢你们。再见，太棒了。谢谢你们。再见，亲爱的。再见。再见，太棒了。
That'll start your week. Happy Monday everybody. You have great Sarah Paulson to give you a nice little jolt of love and energy. She is the best. She's something else. She's funny. And by the way, and everything she's done,
这能给你的这一周开个好头。大家周一快乐。有伟大的莎拉·帕尔森给你们带来满满的爱与能量。她是最棒的。她可真不一般。她很有趣。顺便说一句，还有她演的所有作品，
like you said, Jay, she doesn't, I know we say it a lot about a lot of people, but never terrible. Never terrible. She's one of those people who's always good no matter what she does. Yeah, she's so great. No matter what she's in.
就像你说的，杰伊，她从来不——我知道我们对很多人都这么说，但她从来没有演砸过。从来没演砸过。她是那种不管演什么都一直很棒的人。对，她太棒了。不管她演什么。
She's also just like, just to be around is, as you can see, it just makes your day, makes your night. And you put her and Amanda Pete together, a couple of best friends there, you know, you're just, you're flying for a week. Are they old school best friends? She and Amanda Pete. Yeah, it's like, you watch them, it's like a ticket to a free show.
而且她这个人，正如你所看到的，光是和她在一起就能点亮你的一天，点亮你的夜晚。你把她和阿曼达·皮特凑在一块儿，两个好朋友，你知道的，你这一周都得飘。她们是老朋友了吗？她和阿曼达·皮特。对，你看她们俩，就像是买了一张免费演出的门票。
They just go, go, go, and it's fun and engaging and charming and yeah, it's great. Well, I know, I said it already to her, but I'm really excited about her and the award shows coming up for her in New York. I think she's gonna kill it and I'm so glad she was here. Oh, are you waiting for her vibe? Oh, sorry.
她们俩滔滔不绝，既有趣又迷人，真的太棒了。好吧，我知道，我已经对她说过拉，但我真的很为她以及她在纽约即将到来的颁奖典礼感到兴奋。我觉得她肯定会大获成功的，我很高兴她今天能来。哦，你是在等她的那个梗吗？哦，对不起。
No, no, no, I didn't know. Cause you were just, no, I was just serious. You take the initiative, you've got a head full of steam going towards the vibe. And then it was just a fucking, and then it was just an absolute peer out. Yeah, I know. Just a fucking.
不，不，不，我不知道。因为你刚才，不，我是认真的。你主动出击，带着满腔热情冲向那个梗。结果却是个Fucking冷场，结果却是个绝对的冷场。对，我懂。简直是个Fucking……
Oh, is there an elephant one? No, no, no, no. It was like. No, no, no, no. Let's see. Let's see. Oh, let's see. Let's see, yeah. So we see. Oh, let's see.
哦，有个大象的梗吗？不，不，不，不。就像是。不，不，不，不。让我们看看。让我们看看。哦，让我们看看。让我们看看，对。所以我们看看。哦，让我们看看。
Let's see. So we think the Tonys, Trish, and then that one. Let's see Trish. Monica Lewinsky. Nothing about the elephant, right? How about movies versus theater? Ryan Murphy. Well, she's on New York.
让我们看看。所以我们觉得托尼奖，特里莎，然后是那个。让我们看看特里莎。莫妮卡·莱温斯基。没有关于大象的梗，对吧？电影和戏剧比起来怎么样？瑞恩·墨菲。好吧，她在纽约。
She's in New York. She's also in Los Angeles often, so maybe she's buying coastal, we could use buying coastal. Oh, yeah, we've done it a few times. We've done coastal quite a bit. We've done it a few times. We've done Biden, we've done a Biden, yeah. We did, we did. Take a bite from the apple in New York.
她在纽约。她也经常在洛杉矶，所以也许她是两栖发展，我们可以用“两栖发展”。哦，对，我们用过好几次了。我们用过好几次“两栖发展”了。我们用过好几次了。我们用过拜登，用过一个拜登，对。我们用过，我们用过。在纽约咬一口大苹果。
Okay, go ahead. Yeah. Sean. Hey. So what's up? Hey, Sean. Hey. So what's up? Hey, Sean. Hey. You know, the theater, the Tabasco theater that she's in is actually...
好了，继续。对。肖恩。嘿。怎么了？嘿，肖恩。嘿。怎么了？嘿，肖恩。嘿。你知道的，她参演的那家戏剧院，那个塔巴斯科剧院其实是……
It's actually the Belasco. Yeah, the Belasco, sorry. The Belasco Theater she's actually in. Isn't one of those big theaters like where you... No? Yeah, you can see everything in close. You don't need to sit in the back with one of those opera, you know, things. Those, you know, where they use it to see real far in the theater? You can pull up, like, um, binoculars.
其实是贝拉斯科剧院。对，贝拉斯科，抱歉。她其实是在贝拉斯科剧院。难道不是那种你可以……不？对，你在近处能看清一切。你不需要坐在后面拿着那种歌剧望远镜，你知道的。那种，你知道的，用来在剧院里看得很远的？你可以拿出来，比如，呃，双筒望远镜。
Wow, Will's really blowing up. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barbico. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts.
哇，威尔真是大火特火。聪明。无双。聪明。SmartLess由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjarve和Bennett Barbico100%有机手工打造。如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过Wondry App或Apple Podcasts加入Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。
Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. I'm Shimon Liayi, and I have a new podcast called The Competition. Every year, 50 high school senior girls compete in a massive scholarship competition. I wouldn't say I have an ego problem, but I'm extremely competitive. All of the competitors are used to being the best and the brightest, and they're all vying for a huge cash prize. This will probably be the most intense thing you've ever gone through in your life.
Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们你的想法。我是Shimon Liayi，我有一个新播客叫《竞争》（The Competition）。每年，50名高中女毕业生产生激烈角逐，争夺巨额奖学金。我不会说我有严重的自我中心，但我极好胜。所有的竞争者都习惯了做最优秀、最聪明的佼佼者，而她们都在争夺一笔巨额现金奖。这可能将是你一生中经历过最紧张激烈的体验。
I remember that feeling, because I was one of them. I lost. But now I'm coming back as a judge, and also a kind of teen girl anthropologist. Because if you want to understand what it's like to be a young woman in America today, the competition's not a bad place to start. Hopefully no one will die on stage tonight. From Pineapple Street Studios and Wondry, this is The Competition. Follow The Competition on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts.
我还记得那种感觉，因为我就是其中一员。我失败了。但现在我作为评委回归，同时也算是一名女高中生人类学家。因为如果你想了解当今美国年轻女性的生活状态，《竞争》绝对是一个不错的起点。希望今晚没有人会在舞台上丧命。由Pineapple Street Studios和Wondry联合出品，这就是《竞争》。在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方订阅《竞争》。
You can listen to The Competition early and ad free right now by joining Wondry+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在通过加入Wondry+，你可以提前且无广告收听《竞争》。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。